Ah!
It's like I just started again!
We're back on the tomato farm!
Oh!
Here we are!
Back on the farm!
Oh, I had to get rid of my old skin suit.
So we're here as a tomato again.
My true form.
It is I, Doki.
So anyway, I didn't really have a time to get a new skin suit to put on.
And my old one is in the trash can over there.
So I have to dig it out real quick.
Uh, yeah.
You know what's the best part?
I can actually have a logo on the trash can!
I'm not even monetized anyway.
Like what's gonna happen?
They're gonna demonetize me because I have a logo on a trash can?
I'm not even monetized anyway!
The best part!
I googled dumpster.
Oh, is it copyright free?
Well, those are really maddening.
As long as it's a PNG!
That's all I need!
Oh my god.
Anyway guys, let me go change real quick.
Let me go change real quick into my old suit.
It's a little fucking dirty though.
Give me a sec guys.
Give me a sec.
I gotta go change real quick.
Alright.
Gotta change into my old suit.
Just like old times.
Well.
Here I go.
Alright guys.
I did warn you guys it was gonna be incredibly scuff- I did warn you guys it was gonna be incredibly scuffed.
I had two days.
I'm just...
Alright.
Back then, I used to talk like this.
I used to talk like this.
But now, I lost my youthful optimism.
And now I know the real world.
So now I talk like this.
But yes.
I am back now.
I am back it is I, Doki.
I've grown up.
I realize life is...
It's not as...
It's not as sunny as I thought it was gonna be.
The more I see reality, the lower my voice got.
But...
I think I cried enough.
And I think, I think I cried enough that's for sure.
I had like an entire month to do that.
So obviously...
Obviously, I'm okay.
Oh, okay to be fair to be fair.
I won't say I'm okay To be fair I am But I am surviving I am surviving and I really Okay.
Also we gotta get off the farm.
I'm not tomato anymore.
So yeah, we gotta get off the farm real quick Give me a sec.
There we go.
Yeah Wow Isn't this familiar Wow Doki where's the slides?
Where's the $3,000 lore debut video.
Where's the where's like all the pretty slides and all your information?
I got
Guys there's no way I had time to put all that up into this Oh I I I I I I I I I I I But... but thank you.
You know what we have though?
Oh shit, not like that though.
Oh my gosh.
Not the Zoom thing.
But what we have is... OBS text.
That's what we have.
So that's where all our information is gonna go.
Anyway, for those who are hoping for me to make another statement, that will be at the end of the stream.
So if you want the last statement, I would say it in the end of the stream.
For now, let's just... I haven't streamed for a month plus.
I... I haven't streamed in like so long.
I don't even... Honestly, I don't even remember how to do all of this.
Like... I don't even...
I just... You guys should know, I had to plug in my 4-5 year old PC to get all my old... old graphics and everything.
Because I... I...
And then I had to plug in some fucking Overwatch keyboard.
Just to be like...
Because I...
I was the only keyboard.
With a cable.
It was so dusty.
It was like...
That keyboard was like 7 years old.
I... It was... It was a lot.
It was... It was a lot.
And...
It's like...
I was like...
Where... Where... What?
I didn't even organize any of those files.
It was just all in one download file.
I was like... It was in a download...
Okay, everything... I put everything in a downloads folder.
Because back then...
Um...
4 years ago...
Dota...
I was like...
Never give a fuck about organizing anything.
So everything was just in a folder called downloads.
So then I was like...
What the fuck did I use?
So I had to deal with that...
For a bit.
And then...
And then I was like...
Oh my...
Oh my god.
Okay, it was just...
And then all these new...
Technology...
God, I'm...
Oh my god.
This girl got potential.
Thank you.
I'm so happy.
I really...
I really appreciate that.
Anyway...
So...
Um...
It's just...
It's a lot.
I really...
I saw how many people were in the waiting room.
And I was like...
Oh fuck.
Okay.
I haven't like...
Talked to...
This many people...
In...
So long.
I...
Let's just...
You guys wanna know my schedule before then?
This was my schedule before then?
I wake up...
It's 7 p.m.
I...
I eat...
D...
I eat lunch.
Lunch.
I play video games.
It's 4am.
I eat dinner.
And then I play until I'm so fucking tired that I pass out.
That was the most healthiest schedule I had for almost a month straight.
Wasn't that...
And so, what I saw, I saw, I was like, oh my god.
Now to...
Don't make it depressing, Doki.
Don't make it...
Please.
They wanna watch anime girls.
To escape from reality.
I'm sorry, I need to...
I need to get back into the groove of things, guys.
I'm so sorry.
Anyway.
But...
You know what's funny?
I actually just came back from therapy.
And...
Yeah, I have weekly therapy now because, you know...
That definitely sounded so healthy, right?
So, anyway.
I came back from therapy.
And then my therapist was like...
Wow, Doki.
You are... You sound so different.
And I was like...
Yeah.
I got 32 days to get...
I was like...
Yeah.
But like...
I can...
I can do stuff now.
So...
And then...
But...
But I was like...
I'm streaming...
I'm streaming today.
And then he was like...
He was like...
Wow.
You know...
Like, I can tell you have a...
You're grounded now.
And it's like...
It's like you have a purpose.
And like...
He's right.
Because like...
I can stream now.
I have...
Okay.
I actually...
Even though...
Now it's a serious note.
That is my segue to the serious note thing.
But basically...
I do have...
I have a purpose now.
I do.
I'm not playing video games until...
Looking at 11 in the morning.
Anymore.
I actually have stuff I want to do again.
I actually have goals.
I actually have things I want to do.
Things I want to play.
Things I want to...
Plan.
It's actually crazy.
I...
The moment...
I was finally free...
Like...
I have so many ideas...
In my mind.
And I was...
I was so hap...
Okay.
I was not so happy.
I cried.
I shouldn't say I was so happy.
I was like...
I was happier than what I was a month ago.
That's for sure.
I was happier.
I was so happy.
Anyway.
I was...
I actually have a vision.
And everything.
So like...
He wasn't wrong.
Like...
Instead of...
Not knowing...
What my life was gonna be...
At least now...
I know where my life is going to be now.
So...
He was right.
And then...
And then he was like...
So...
Like...
How's your channel?
I was like...
Oh like...
I got a new channel.
He got 300K subscribers in 2 days.
He was like...
What the...
What?!
He was like...
Okay.
Yeah.
And he was like...
That's insane.
I was like...
Yeah.
But...
He was just like...
Yeah, anyway...
So, it is actually...
Honestly, it's...
What looking forward...
In the future...
The future plans...
As Mia's doki...
Is that...
I do have...
A lot of ideas going in.
Oh my god!
Okay, so...
You know how there's a business inquiries...
Thing?
Apparently we got too many inquiries...
That Google thought it was a bot.
account.
So...
By the way, I have a manager.
Well, I can't say manager-san...
Because he's not Japanese.
He's American.
So it would be weird to call him manager-san.
But...
We made...
You know, we had like...
You know, like... business inquiries.
There's like...
You know, the email doki can read.
And then like...
I got like a message be like...
Hey!
Like, our emails are bouncing.
So I'm gonna like DM you about this.
And I was like... What?
And then... Oh, Mr. Manager.
Yeah, Mr. Manager.
No, really?
That's too many syllables.
What the fuck are you...
Like, it has to like...
Manage... Sorry, I forgot account either.
Like... I never had...
I just had to... I was just playing video games.
Like, what the fuck do I need accounting for?
Alright, Manager...
San.
Okay, it has to be four syllables.
Mr. Manager.
That's five syllables.
That's way too many syllables.
Mr. Man.
Okay, Mr. Man.
Alright, sorry.
Mr. Man.
Um... I was like...
What the fuck's going on?
The emails are bouncing.
And he was like...
Oh, shit.
We're...
We have too many...
Google flagged the email account.
So like...
We're gonna have to use my personal email.
I was just like...
Alright, this isn't... Alright, whatever.
This is not gonna look professional.
But at this point...
We need a business email going on there.
So I'm really...
I'm really sorry about the business inquiries.
And you're like...
Why are the emails bouncing?
Where is the reply?
Um...
We're waiting for Google to like...
Tell us... Be like... You're not a bot.
So...
So we're gonna...
But for now, we have Mr. Man's personal email.
On my...
On the Twitter profile right now.
So we're gonna deal with that.
Anyway, Mr. Man has been...
Oh, god.
Okay.
Anyway...
Mr. Man...
Um... Has been helping out...
A lot.
So I talked about this in...
If you were lucky in...
If you were lucky and you were in...
The chat whenever I popped by...
I gave like little tidbits of updates...
Every so often.
Um...
When he told me...
The thing is...
I was so...
I guess like...
What's the right word?
I was so...
I guess shocked?
I was like...
And like... I don't know.
I don't know how to describe this feeling.
But...
When he was like, what are you gonna do?
And I was like... I wanna do so many projects.
I wanna host events.
I wanna host events...
With so many different...
Indies and...
Different companies in...
In the West.
And everything.
And then...
Mr. Man was like...
Uh...
What's... Did you...
Okay, I'm trying to like phrase this better.
Okay...
Sorry, I haven't talked this much...
In a long time either.
Like...
I don't...
I was not...
I have not talked in a long time.
And...
And then...
He was like...
We can get sponsors for that.
I was like... Huh?
And he was like...
Yeah, you don't have to pay out of your own pocket anymore.
I was like...
What?
I was just like...
I was like...
Wait...
Huh?
And...
That blew my mind.
By the way...
Mark is like...
My mom scolded me about this because...
You know, during all of this...
During...
During all of this...
Um...
She looked at my financials...
And I made zero profit last year.
And I spent it all.
She was like...
And she was like...
You have to spend less.
Because...
You spent...
$200 ,000...
Last year.
And I...
I was like...
That hurt.
Oh...
But then...
When Mr. Mad was like...
All those projects you want to do...
All of that...
You want to do...
You don't have to...
You won't be spending...
$200,000.
I was...
I was so...
I just blew my mind.
I...
I couldn't believe it.
I couldn't believe...
Those were my expenses...
Last year.
I just...
I just really like...
I just really like projects.
I have a problem.
I have...
Oh my god.
Anyway...
I want to say...
Leading up to that...
I really do want to say...
Thank you everybody...
For...
For the immense support...
Throughout all of this...
And so many...
So many...
Oh my god.
There's so many of you.
There's...
And so many...
So many donations.
So many viewers.
And so many support...
From so many different people.
I just...
Thank you.
I don't know.
I...
I received a lot of messages.
A lot of...
Like...
So many of my friends...
From... Like... I made over...
Like old friends, new friends...
Reaching out...
And...
And giving their support...
And everything...
It...
It really was...
I... I cried so much.
I know I keep saying that, but like...
I... I feel... I felt like...
I cried like...
At least twice a day.
And...
But recently...
Recently... Recently...
They... They have been...
Happy tears.
And...
Honestly, like...
I...
I don't know how much I can thank you guys.
And... I really...
Hope I can...
Repay all of you...
In the future...
For... Like everything you guys have done.
And...
I was so surprised because...
Like...
My friends over at...
Apex and EA...
Also... They like...
You know like...
When I put up the waiting room...
For the stream...
One of the Apex...
One of the Apex staff members...
Like messaged me...
And was like...
Sending them their support...
And was like saying...
Was like screenshotting the chat's waiting room...
And stuff...
And was just...
Just...
Just being so supportive and everything...
And...
I... It was just... Oh my gosh...
I...
I honestly...
I just... Everything...
I don't know... I...
I didn't expect...
Really...
I felt like it was like...
You know...
End of the world...
It's hard to be hopeful after what happened...
You know...
It's hard... It's hard...
To be hopeful...
I honestly...
But then... Then I saw...
So many support...
And all the love...
And all the messages...
I got...
Throughout the past two days...
And...
I'm honestly... I'm...
I'm just so overwhelmed...
I've been so...
So overwhelmed...
And I want to say thank you everybody...
I don't... I...
I don't know what to do about you guys...
I'm just... I'm just a fucking...
Stupid girl...
I'm just...
It's crazy... It really...
It really is... And...
I...
I really did feel very hopeless...
For...
For a while now...
And... And just to see all this love...
And...
Being...
I guess like...
More positive about my future now...
And also...
Oh my god...
Oh my...
It's just...
It's hard to like...
Put things in words...
I'm like stammering and...
And pausing so much because...
It's really hard to put...
Words into...
The emotion...
Like I feel right now...
And...
Really... I know I keep saying thank you...
I keep saying thank you...
But really... Thank you everyone...
I...
I really... I'm lining up...
A lot of...
Collabs for...
Next week...
Um... Because I really...
Want to get back into swing of things...
And...
Really I just...
I wanna...
I really miss streaming...
I really... really...
Do...
When I wasn't...
I wasn't online streaming...
During those...
Long fucking days...
Haha...
Oh my god... During those...
It...
Felt... I was...
Very miserable...
Because... I honestly...
I really do enjoy streaming...
I really enjoy talking to all...
You guys... I really enjoy doing...
Okay...
What I found figured out...
Is that...
I...
Do not like playing video games...
If I'm not like...
Single player... Okay I try to play...
I... I tried...
I try to play single player games...
With nobody watching me...
But it was not...
The same... It was...
It was not the same...
And you know what I did?
I would...
I would drag my friends...
And a...
In like a discord call...
And I'd be like... Watch me play...
And then... Listen to me...
Commentate...
Hahaha...
I was like...
Alright... You're gonna pretend to be my chat...
And I'm gonna be...
Commentating while I play this game...
Hahaha...
Oh my god... Okay... I saw someone said...
Chat was like... Without the...
Yes!
Oh my god...
There was game I was playing...
And I literally dragged one of my friends...
To watch me play this game...
So like... When we got to the puzzle parts...
I would be like...
Backseat me...
Hahaha...
Like...
Hahaha... I'd be like...
What's the answer?
Hahaha... It's...
Backseating time...
So... Um...
I do miss that...
I actually... I really do miss the backseating...
I can't think for myself...
I can't... But like...
Oh my god...
Guys... Alright...
What games do you guys... Okay... But yeah...
Guys... I...
Okay... We're not gonna have a stream tomorrow...
Because...
I only... Okay...
So...
I was just like... I need a stream...
But I can't stream tomorrow... Like you know...
When the fucking news dropped...
I was like... Do I stream tomorrow?
Or the day after tomorrow?
Because you know... It was like...
Fucking... 5 in the morning...
So I was like...
Okay...
We're gonna do the day after tomorrow...
Because... I need to process...
All of this... Because I'm not processing...
Anything... So...
So I was just like...
Alright...
I'm gonna... Day after tomorrow...
I'll stream...
My first stream...
And I'm just... I need to slowly get into it...
But next week is gonna be our very first schedule...
Actual...
I don't have a schedule... I saw so many...
Schedule templates... Thank you so much...
For using Doki Gallery...
Because I saw so many assets...
And everything...
And thank you guys so much...
Um... I need to find...
A schedule...
Assets... I know there are more schedule assets...
For those who made...
A schedule assets... Can you guys make it into like...
The square?
Because it fits into like...
I like it when it's not...
Landscape... But like...
You know the square?
I don't know how to describe it... You know the square shape...
Instead of the landscape... It's not... Was it...
Full square?
I don't... Guys it's been so long...
I don't even remember what like...
You know...
Back then looked like... I... I need to choose...
I don't... I'm trying to choose words carefully...
Because like... I don't know what...
What vocabulary it is anymore...
Portrait...
But it's not full portrait...
It's like... I don't know...
You know... What it looks like...
What it looks nice on mobile type deal...
Like I know there was a lot of landscape ones...
But like... I would like...
The non landscape...
It was not... Was it full portrait?
Size dimensions?
I don't remember...
Anyway...
Anyway... Yes... 4 to 3...
Thank you...
See?
This is why I need a stream... If I was by myself...
I wouldn't have that...
Like...
This is exactly why people need a stream...
Like... I'm not gonna think for myself...
I can literally like... I can like...
Literally make someone else think for me...
Umm... And that's why...
It's a 4 by 3... There we go...
Anyway... Umm...
Uhh...
Thank you guys so much... I really...
There's so many... There's so many...
Beautiful artwork...
I... When I came back...
You know...
And...
Just... All the artists...
You know when I said I loved art...
I've always supported artists...
I was...
Back then...
I was everywhere... Like... Not me...
But like... Okay... Me...
A lot... I...
I commissioned a lot...
Of artists...
I mean...
So...
Cause I love art...
I really... I really...
Really... I just love art...
And...
I was... You know...
There's so many artists...
That... Drew me...
And I was... I... I was just... I was so emotional...
I was so emotional...
When all of you guys started posting old artwork...
And old... Like... Old commissions...
That... That you've done...
Over the years...
And then seeing them being how...
I started their art career...
Or like introduced them to...
VTubing... And stuff...
And like... Like... Oh... Like...
Oh... I... You were like...
The first person that ever commissioned me... And stuff like that...
And...
I... Thank you...
I... I'm just surprised...
You remembered me...
Fun fact!
Those posts are delet... I wish I didn't delete so...
Oh my god...
I wish I didn't...
I wish I didn't delete so much of my...
Like... Tweets and history...
Um...
Because... I'm gonna fuck thought I was gonna...
Be active here again... But...
Life has...
Life... Life is unpredictable...
But... Fun fact!
I...
Was...
One of ones... That introduced...
Skeb...
To...
To like a lot of people on Twitter...
I had like a viral...
Tweet about...
Because at that time...
At that time...
No one really knew what that website was...
And I actually...
Made a tweet about it... And a guide...
On how to use it...
Hahahaha...
Yeah...
I actually...
Yeah... I actually... I was like...
One... Like the first people that like...
Discovered it and like...
Tweeted it out and stuff for everybody...
Um... To like introduce it...
I deleted... Okay a lot...
There's like at a certain year... Like a lot of those tweets are...
Like it... My... If you like...
My tweet history now... It's like...
At this time... It stops at a certain time of year...
Because obviously everything...
Fucking down there...
Is all gone now...
Hahahaha...
Oh my god...
Yeah...
And...
Uh... I remember...
Uh...
I think... I wasn't like...
I was always interested in...
Like... VTubing... And...
Everything... And...
Um... I remember...
You know...
I actually... Uh...
Was one of the...
First... Like...
Couple of... Like... One of the earliest...
Um...
IronVertex...
Like... Customers...
Back then...
Super early... Super duper early...
Like...
Hahahaha...
Back when VTubing wasn't like...
Like... Super big yet...
And... It is...
Actually... Yeah... Yeah... You might...
I don't even know if you can... I'm pretty sure you can still find...
Find... Like me...
On... On... Like one of the...
Like... The...
One of their portfolios...
Um... Because I've always been like...
Super interested in it... Anyway!
For those who are wondering...
Beneath this tomato form...
Um... This tomato...
Will get a...
Not soon...
Hahahaha...
Not...
Not soon...
Because art takes a long time...
Sorry... Sorry... Skin suit designing...
You know... Because it's real skin...
And real hair...
Sorry... Immersion...
Hahahaha...
That...
Um...
Is...
I don't know... This skin suit is... Honestly...
It's... It's... It's three...
Three plus years... Okay... It's not just three...
It's three... It's like almost four years old...
It's four years old... And this tomato...
I've... Has not washed...
This skin suit in a long time... For it lived...
In the dumpster... While I was gone...
And now I'm back here...
Hahahaha... Right now I'm back here...
Hahahaha...
Alright!
Anyway!
Anyway... Information time...
Information time... Alright...
Anyway...
Because obviously...
You know... What does two days of work...
Got me... What if two days...
Of stuff I did on this stream...
Here is...
The slide...
I.e.
The text...
Alright!
Birthday!
Birthday...
Yes...
Oh my gosh... Shift does that?
Sorry... Hahahaha...
Hahahaha...
Sorry...
I don't know my bindings...
Alright!
Birthday... So I might... Like...
My face malfunction sometimes...
So...
Hahahaha...
Birthday!
Oh my god!
Doki!
You actually...
Your birthday is...
Actually July 4th?
Yes... Hahahaha...
Hahahaha...
Alright...
Anyway...
July 4th... The most...
Non... The most...
American Canadian out there...
Uh...
My birthday...
Is actually...
Yes... July 4th...
Oh my god!
I know!
Hahahaha...
Alright!
Speaking of like... Canadian...
I said this in chat...
When this all happened...
But... Basically...
Obviously... My DMs are...
You know... Open... So...
Which isn't... Oh my gosh...
I shouldn't have said that... Because now people are gonna be like...
Oh my god!
We're gonna fucking...
Message Doki on her... On the DMs...
There's so many...
I'll just let you guys know...
I'll be closing them very soon...
It's just a little adjustment period...
Because like... You know...
Our... Our...
My... Mr. Man's email address...
Is...
Not doing so well right now... So...
Hahahaha...
But... Obviously...
Throughout all of this... That happened...
Throughout all of this that happened...
Obviously...
You know... I'd get some...
Pretty... Pretty...
Weird DMs... And...
One of them...
There was a lot going on... But one... One of them...
It was...
Entertainment at that point... Because... Like...
It just got funnier...
And funnier as it went on...
Uh... But basically...
Uh... They were like...
You live in Canada!
And I...
Like... As if it's like...
A dox...
Hahahaha...
Like... You're like...
I got you!
You're Canadian!
And I'm like... Okay... So...
Hahahaha...
Hahahaha... Like... As... As...
As a threat... So... I was just...
I... I... I... I...
I don't know... I... I...
At that point I was just like...
You know...
At that point you sort of feel a bit... Sorry...
Hahahaha...
Because... Like...
What goes in your mind...
Being like...
Oh my god... I got it...
She lives in the second largest...
Largest country in the world...
I got her... Like...
Oh my god... I'll know exactly...
Where she is now...
Ohhhhh...
Also... I'll give like a little help too...
I'm on the west coast... If that...
Helps out...
Hahahaha...
Oh...
Also... Um... Regarding...
Um...
Other things... Um...
I will... Mr. Man is working on...
Opening a PO box...
For...
For... Um... Everybody...
And I'm hoping for...
A PO box... You guys can send...
In... Um...
You guys can send...
Like... You know... No food...
Um...
Because... That's always...
Fucking sketchy...
I don't...
That's... That's always...
Fucking sketchy... Um...
There's gonna be guidelines...
That's Mr. Man's job...
Not my job...
Um... But... There's gonna be...
Uh... You can send in...
Like... You know...
Fan merch if you want to...
Or like... Fan mail...
And... Um...
Gifts and stuff...
And... He's gonna vet it...
And then send it back to me...
So... Um...
Don't write anything too weird...
Because... He's gonna...
Read all of it...
He's gonna...
You know... He's gonna read it...
Unless you wanna send Mr. Man some...
Fan mail... And...
Maybe he's into... Like...
Whatever freaky shit you wanna send him...
Um... But like...
Uh... He's gonna be reading all the...
Fan mail to make sure... You know...
I don't know... Like...
It be fucked up if you just send me some hate mail...
Like... I've...
You know... I've already been through a lot...
So... I don't think...
Um... I'm literally going to therapy...
So... I don't really wanna go to my...
Therapist next week and be like...
So yeah... My manager sent me...
Hate mail... Um...
I don't really know what that means in general...
Or like... What he really thinks about me...
So...
Uh... So yes...
Anyway... I like how all I wrote was...
Birthday...
I... I actually had like other stuff...
I want... Okay... Give me a sec...
I wrote all of this down...
I was like... Here is the plan...
Doki... Here is the...
Plan... On like...
Where you're supposed to go with all of this...
Which is... Okay...
I just want you guys to know...
Plan... What I wrote for...
The plan... Is...
Birthday...
Doxy story...
Doki Doge...
Tags...
That's the... That's the...
Where it's leading to...
Anyway... Um...
Doki Doge...
Which came first?
Of course I love my...
Well...
Now I love myself again...
We gotta be realistic here...
Um...
I love myself again...
So...
But back then...
I really loved myself...
So... When I got Doki Doge...
I named him after me...
So...
Doki Doge...
But then...
It might get a little confusing...
So...
Because...
You know... Doki Doge...
It might get a little bit confusing...
Also... There's like... It's just too many D's...
So...
We might give him a little nickname...
It... Just to distinguish between...
Doki 1 and Doki 2...
And I'm very willing...
Uh...
To let you guys decide...
What... Doki Doge...
Nickname is...
So you guys...
Can decide...
Doki Doge's nickname...
Guys...
You guys can decide...
Oh my god...
Don't be so...
Guys...
I'm trying to like...
Guys... You guys can decide...
Doki Doge's nickname...
That I'll be using...
On stream...
Just so we can distinguish...
Doki 2...
Oh my god...
Amuse Glacier...
What a great suggestion...
Through random picking...
Through...
Sheer randomness...
And random picking...
I feel like... I don't know...
I feel like... For some reason...
We can call him...
Doki Ember Doge...
Oh no!
Thank you Glacier...
I just closed my eyes...
And like... Picked one name on random...
But like... It's spelled with an A...
Just so you guys know...
Doki Ember Doge...
What is this?
Oh sorry... That's Twitch Alert...
Because I haven't set up YouTube Alerts yet...
I haven't...
I haven't set up YouTube Alerts yet...
So...
You can call Doki Doge...
Amber...
If you like...
Also like... It helps out...
Because I really don't want to say Doki Doge or Doki a lot...
So... His middle name is now...
Doki Ember Doge...
Amber for short...
So... And he...
I feel like he's like... Super used to it anyway...
At this point...
He's like...
Anyway...
This is how scuffed it was...
I didn't even set up...
I didn't even set up like...
YouTube Alerts...
Because I was like...
I'm not even monetized...
So I'll just set up Twitch Alerts...
Like I mean I had Twitch Alerts...
So I was just like...
Just... Whenever I got monetized...
I was like...
Yay...
Tags...
I really... I was...
The only one I have so far...
Is...
Doki Gallery...
I didn't want to put art on there...
Because... I don't know...
For some reason...
I realized...
I don't know... From research I guess...
That when you put art in any art tag...
Like the word art in there...
It...
Oh my god... Dad...
Hahahaha...
Um...
But...
It gives you like... you know...
A lot of like... NFTs...
Hahahaha...
And bots...
So... By sheer research...
And I don't know... Maybe... Wow...
Maybe some like... It came to me in a dream...
I realized that...
I'm never using art...
For an art tag ever again...
Hahahaha...
So... So our...
Our...
Our art tag is...
Doki Gallery...
We're gonna have...
I guess like... Tags suggest... You know what...
We're just gonna do it to the point...
Because we're retiring this tag anyway...
But any... For any tag suggestions...
And names... Feel...
Oh my gosh... Feel... I might make some funny faces...
While I'm typing... Just so you guys know...
Um... Oh my god... That...
Sorry... Hahahaha...
Hahahaha...
Tag...
Suggestions...
Alright... Tag suggestions...
Um...
Let's see...
I don't know... Hashtag...
Doki...
Tag suggestions...
Hahahaha...
Alright...
Um...
You wanna suggest tags... It is...
Hashtag... Doki...
Tags... Tag suggestions...
There we go...
So...
Any... Like you know...
Uh... Like...
The usual tags...
I guess like... Live tag...
Memes tag...
Um...
I forgot...
I'm sorry... It's... Please...
Give me a... It's been a month plus...
It's actually... It's been...
So long...
Hahahaha...
It's... It's been so long...
I... I was like... Fuck...
What do we use for tags again?
I just remembered the live tag... The memes tag...
The... Oh!
Shrine!
Yes!
We're bringing back the shrine...
Oh... Doki Shrine...
I'm just gonna... It's to the point...
I swear to god... If someone already has Doki Shrine...
I... This is the worst part because...
It's like... Doki is like...
It's like...
It's like a real word...
I feel like someone already...
Guys, don't use Doki Shrine...
Because I have a feeling that Doki Shrine...
Is an actual real tag...
Because it makes sense when you put it together...
So...
Give a shrine tag somewhere...
Um...
Uh... Where was I?
Where was I?
Uh...
Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba...
Fuck.
Okay.
Uh...
My brain is like on cog wheels right now...
Trying to get back into the groove of things...
Because it's like...
I had... I had a system...
Of everything I... Oh wait, no.
I already finished...
Everything I want to say... Right?
I had...
I... Literally...
The order of this... The chronological order of this...
Was...
Birthday.
Doxing story.
Doki Doge.
Doki Amber Doge.
Tags.
Oh!
Merch!
I don't know if Mr. Man has like... finished setting... Okay!
To get started on your Doki Shrine.
We're relaunching!
Relaunching the original!
The original!
The original Doki Merch!
Please...
applaud Mr. Man because two hours before the stream...
I was like, okay...
Can you like, put these things up on the store?
I'll give you the information and illustration.
Just...
put it all up there.
I don't have time.
So...
Let me check real quick if the store is up yet.
Let's see... Oh!
Please no!
Wait!
That was when I asked him...
That's when he talked about like reading...
Like getting Fat Mel directed at him.
And he's like, I don't really want to read.
I don't really...
I don't want to read the freaky ones directed at me.
Alright.
Mr. Man, are you...
Do you have the store link?
If not, it's okay.
We can segue into something else.
Also...
Also, also, also, also, also...
We will have a Lunar New Year stream!
Because...
As someone that, you know...
I celebrate Lunar New Year...
You know...
Due to my culture...
And...
The holiday really does mean a lot to me.
It really does mean a lot to me.
And...
It's the year of...
You know...
Of new beginnings.
So...
I was going to save this on Lunar New Year.
But then I was just like...
I just want to spoil you guys a little bit.
So...
We will be having...
Lunar New Year merch.
Which will come out on Lunar New Year.
And...
This will be...
This will be the acrylic stand.
For...
It's not finished yet.
It's still a draft.
But this is one of the Lunar New Year...
Merch that I'm going to be selling.
And...
There is one more.
I am really, really, really excited about.
This one I am super happy about.
This is a little preview.
But I will have some...
RED POCKET EVOLOPES!
This is the preview!
Oh my god!
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh, when you see the full illustrations, it's like actually...
I'm... I cannot wait.
But we're gonna have red pocket envelopes too.
This is obviously just a little preview.
So when, you know, during Lunar New Year, when you know, whoa!
You get to see the whole thing!
Whoa!
But we're gonna have a three pack of some Lunar New Year envelopes.
So you can use it to...
Honestly, like honestly the best advice is to like never get married.
So you can always receive red pocket envelopes.
So honestly just keep it for display because why the fuck would you want to give money to little kids?
Like...
Because I was a little kid back then too.
And I was a little kid back then too.
And I abused the shit of the Lunar New Year system.
As in I would go and hang out at my grandpa's place.
Because he was the head of the family.
And per tradition in Lunar New Year...
In Lunar New Year in China...
You have to go to the head of the family...
Like place and pay your respect.
So I would stay there overnight.
I would stay there overnight.
And because I was the first granddaughter...
That has the...
That was my dad...
Like you know because you know...
My dad's a man.
So...
So I have his last name Mr. Bird.
I would get more money.
And that's how you cheese the system.
Make sure...
Go to...
Make sure you go to the head of the family's place.
Stay overnight.
Never get married.
So you can get more money and never have to give away money.
There you go.
Just be born...
And be born first.
And before...
No, no, no, no.
Born first...
But for your dad's side.
And that's how you do it.
As long as...
As long as you do that...
He has so much money.
And go to every family dinner.
Make sure you go to every single family dinner.
Because...
Sometimes they forgot.
They gave you this...
Gave you an envelope already.
So...
Sometimes they forget to give you an envelope already.
They give it to you again.
Because they give so many envelopes.
They actually forget.
And then you have to make sure if you are the firstborn...
Firstborn...
Grandchildren.
Make sure you tell them that.
Because they'll be like...
Oh my god.
That's Doki.
That's Mr. Bird.
That's Grandpa Bird's firstborn...
Grand...
We gotta give her the bigger ones.
Genius.
Doki, what if i'm not the first born?
You will be soon.
Because they'll have to get married.
If you never get married...
One day...
You will become...
Then you move up because...
If you never get married, the firstborn would have to get married so you become the firstborn.
So their firstborn money will go to you.
There you go.
And that's why you should never get married.
If you celebrate Lunar New Year.
Because I don't know, some people might be like...
Badoki, I don't celebrate Lunar New Year.
I was gonna say...
That just sucks for you.
At that point, I don't know.
Sorry, I don't know.
If you don't celebrate Lunar New Year at that point, I don't know.
I don't know.
That just...
Well, just sucks to you, I guess.
Stop leaking the strategy.
How many firstborns are out there?
This is only reserved for firstborn children only.
Who are not married.
I'm not married.
Alright, sorry.
That was a weird...
I haven't... guys, I haven't tangent in so long.
It's actually been...
So long since I've tangent.
It's so weird.
I haven't talked this long in a...
I... oh my gosh.
I haven't talked this long in a while.
Oh yes.
What are you guys?
You're... I don't really want you guys to be...
Bark Knights.
Because...
Um...
To be honest...
Uh...
I feel like...
The Bark Knights...
Are the past...
Well...
Past past.
Current.
This is current now.
I know it's a bit mindfucky, but this...
Past current life.
I guess that's how you explain it.
I feel like we've grown...
As a... as a person...
I'm a person now.
Actually you can say I'm a tomato.
I mean...
How we grown...
The skin suit I'm a person now.
Well...
She takes off her hat.
She has some animal character.
We'll never know.
We'll never know what's under this hat.
Uh...
Um...
So I honestly...
I don't know.
Um...
If you wanna like suggest...
What you guys wanna be called...
Uh...
And obviously we can just...
Decide and chat right now.
What you guys wanna be called.
Um...
Because I really...
I...
I don't want you guys to be...
Bark knights.
And...
I don't know what you guys are.
Is it a grid?
Oh yeah.
What are you though?
Doki?
Well...
I don't know if you guys heard...
About evolution.
But like...
I'm a bird now.
Whoa...
So clever.
As if like...
200,000 people didn't make the same joke...
And I just stole it off chat.
Uh...
Because...
This thief never steals.
Um...
Free birds.
Okay.
It just doesn't...
Make sense.
Free birds.
I know you guys wanna be called...
But like...
It...
If I use that in the sentence...
That's the hardest part.
Cause you're like...
You want it to be...
Usable...
In the sentence as well.
So like...
Free birds isn't like...
The best way to say stuff.
So...
So like...
I actually don't even know what you guys are.
There's so many like different...
designs too.
We'll figure that out.
We'll have a...
We'll have like a fan mascot stream in the future.
Whenever I figure out my schedule and everything.
So don't worry guys.
We're gonna have a fan mascot.
A fan mascot stream where we draw the fan mascot in the next time.
But for now, I do really would like to...
I do really want to...
decide a name for all of you guys.
Because I don't know.
I don't fucking know what to call you.
We need some material to work with.
I'm sorry!
I found out two days ago.
I can use that joke because I'm the depressed one here.
Like you just got...
I've been through so much at this point.
It's all about laughing it off at that point.
Because like...
If I stop and think and realize the reality of everything...
It will not be great for me.
So...
We have to...
We just have to laugh it off sometimes.
The fu- I'm not calling you guys the fucking flock.
The raft.
Don't the fuck you guys have a basketball team?
No.
Absolutely not.
Look, I'm not gonna have fucking little tomatoes running around.
Not have that.
Tomatoes are for- Tiny tomatoes are for eating.
Big tomatoes are for eating.
Those tomatoes are for eating little tiny tomatoes.
We're not...
I'm not calling you guys the nuggets.
What...
What are these names?
I came back for you guys to backseat me better.
Yes!
It's supposed to be better backseaters.
Like...
That's a hockey team.
Alright guys.
Guys!
Alright.
Apparently...
Right now...
Why must you hate all our i- Why must you hate all our ideas?
Well...
I don't even know this...
But...
It's not that I hate all your ideas...
But your ideas are pretty fucking terrible.
Look!
I get it!
It's been a while!
You guys gotta get all the terrible ideas out first before we hit the good ones.
So like, I get it.
You haven't let them out yet in a long time.
You know, you haven't said all these...
You've been keeping all these terrible ideas in you for so long.
So like, eventually...
You know, you get all that out of your system.
And fall into the routines.
Good ideas will start coming out.
The okey doke...
Oh my...
Are we like what?
In kindergarten?
Hello little okey doke!
Little okey dokes!
Are you ready to learn the alphabets?
Little okey dokey!
No...
The...
The wingman...
Hello wingman...
No...
Absolutely not!
We're not the wingman!
Okay!
Alright, I feel like...
I feel like all of us are...
Having trouble here.
So...
Moving on...
Use the dokey tag suggestion.
Use the dokey tag suggestion...
To...
Figure out...
You know...
You know, what...
What you...
What you wanna be called!
What you wanna be called.
Because...
At the moment...
I like how it's like...
I like how there's...
Literally two...
I think I didn't make a powerpoint slide.
Because these are the two things I really...
Like...
Likes and dislikes!
I don't...
You're...
At this point...
I feel like we all...
To be fair...
Who the fuck watches...
Goes back to watch just for the likes and dislikes.
Like...
I'm...
I'm gonna say it.
Like...
Who the fuck actually...
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
Oh wait!
That's fine!
I'm not even monetized.
Oh shit!
That scared the shit out of me.
Oh my god!
Where the fuck is the ad?
There we go.
I...
I honestly...
I'm just...
Even though I'm not monetized...
I really don't want this thing getting...
Like...
This song is blocked in these countries.
Because that would fucking suck.
That would actually fucking suck.
Where was I?
Wait...
What was I talking about before I got...
Before...
Fuck!
What was I talking about?
God damn it!
Now I have freebirds stuck in my head.
We're not gonna be called freebirds!
It doesn't...
I know you guys...
Holy shit, LordPancake!
I'm so sorry.
Like, if you all...
Thank you so much for the donation.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm gonna say it.
Like, I don't look back to a VTuber debut.
Honestly, it's not even a debut.
I'm just back.
Like, to be like...
Wait!
I have my debut stream on.
So...
That's right!
I'm not making it because...
Why did I even put my birthday?
You can literally look at the debut.
I'm not making it because...
Oh, I have my debut stream that's still on this channel from four years ago.
It's still there!
Like...
I can't believe I forgot I've debuted before.
And...
Holy shit!
Guys, I've actually debuted before.
So, you can look at the debut pod for, like, likes and dislikes.
Why the fuck did I even put birthday?
Alright, anyway.
But the tag's back there.
The...
They're like, retired.
Because it's new me.
New me, new life.
I like how people are still like, What about Freebirds?
We're not gonna be Freebirds.
The reason why we're not gonna be Freebirds is that it doesn't...
It doesn't like, roll off the tongue as good as you guys think it does.
It doesn't...
Also...
Like, how do you f- How the f- do you visualize that?
Like...
It's harder for all of us to like, think of like, what you all look like if you're called Freebirds.
So don't worry, we'll figure that out.
We'll figure that out soon.
But...
Oh my god.
It's actually... it's...
It's actually, it's just been wild.
I feel like I haven't...
I feel like I'm losing stamina.
Because like, I haven't talked...
This long.
In a very long time.
And...
I'm so... I'm just...
I'm not used to it.
But I also...
I...
I miss it so much.
I really do.
I...
I really... I really miss this.
A lot.
And...
I really just...
I miss just talking with all of you.
And...
And just...
I guess like...
Restarting.
And...
Oh my god.
There's just so much potential.
And...
Let's try...
Let's try and aim for 500k subscribers by the end of this year.
Okay guys?
You guys think we can do it?
I think that's...
I think like goals wise...
I would love to hit...
Five...
Alright goals!
Oh my god goals!
Almost forgot.
I think...
It'll be 500k subscribers by the end of this year.
And then my dream goal would be a million subscribers.
And...
I...
I guess like...
The PC...
A PC sponsor.
And...
A gaming gear sponsor.
Oh my gosh.
I would love to have a gaming gear sponsor.
I want...
I want a...
You know like those like gamer mouse pads?
You know?
Like...
Cause okay.
I love when people are like...
Why the fuck do you have two mouse pads?
You don't fucking understand!
Alright.
For all you non-gamers out there.
You have a normal desk mat.
That's like cute.
Or I don't know.
Like...
Anime like JJK on there or some shit.
I don't...
I don't know.
Usually it's either...
Something fucking cute.
Or like...
The anime of the year.
Which would be...
I guess like JJK.
And then...
On top of it...
You have a...
Second...
Mouse pad on top of it.
And it's the gamer mouse pad.
So it's like...
I use the...
What the fuck do I use?
I think I use the Hien FX.
I can't read.
It's been used a while.
So I use the Hien FX.
But there's like Skypad and stuff like that.
Like if you want to use glass like mouse pad.
There's like Skypad.
And I would love to have a gaming gear.
I should write this down.
But like...
You guys can write it down for me.
I...
But honestly...
That would be a dream come true for me as well.
It's crazy.
I...
So...
So many people...
Reached out to me for...
To like...
For like...
Sponsors and like...
Deals and all that stuff.
And I'm not used to it.
At all.
You know?
I've always thought it wasn't marketable.
So...
I've...
I have a huge...
I can't...
I've always had a huge imposter syndrome.
And I've...
Oh my god, like...
The stuff that Mr. Man sent to me...
I was just...
I was like, what?
They were like, oh yeah, this, this, and then...
Do this, and...
I was like...
Huh?
What?
And...
I just never... I don't know.
It's just crazy.
It really...
Really is.
And... I'm getting emotional.
I told myself I shouldn't cry.
Because I've cried too much.
I really have cried way, way too fucking much.
And... it's just...
I was so surprised.
I never thought I'd...
You know, people would want me to advertise their stuff.
But I was just this anime girl that played video games.
And do stupid shit sometimes.
Okay, maybe not sometimes.
Maybe apparently not sometimes.
It's nice to laugh though.
It's nice to laugh again.
Um...
It really is.
I don't think I've laughed...
I haven't laughed this much in a while now.
And...
It's nice to...
Be happy.
For this moment.
And... I wanna say thank you.
Thank you everybody.
Um...
I like how I say everybody because you guys have no name yet.
But...
Thank you.
Thank you everyone.
It really... It really is.
Um...
Uh...
Just... Thank you for...
Making me laugh.
Again.
And...
I hope I can make you guys laugh again as well.
I miss laughing with all of you.
And...
Oh my gosh.
You know what we can finally do?
A members Minecraft server.
But I can't stream it in members.
I can finally...
I can finally do it!
I advise...
Minecraft server!
But I can't stream it in members though.
I guess they're still.
Even though, even though I'm like...
Well, still can't do everything...
And... Garfield Cart.
They can't say no if I never ask.
A little pause... and we are back.
Oh my god!
The best part.
Freddy Fish!
Can't say no!
Creative Commons!
I was gonna say America, but I'm like...
I told you the most American Canadian out there.
Transformative!
This is transformative work.
Alright, sorry.
The first joke was like Oh my, let me ask for...
Oh, we don't have to anymore.
Oh my god!
Well...
I'm an indie!
I have transformative work!
Alright, anyway, for those who are wondering...
Platforms...
Oh my god!
Ichigo Games!
And like, you know like...
I really always wanted to just find random games on Steam and just be like...
Anyway...
What was I gonna say?
Fuck!
Okay.
Shit, okay, wait, wait.
I had something.
I had something right there.
God damn it, never mind.
I forgot.
I actually...
I actually forgot what I was gonna say.
Okay, but yes.
One of my first streams I really wanted to do was...
Did you guys know there's private Neopets server?
Oh my god!
I was talking to Gumi.
You know...
Gumi.
One of my best friends for like seven fucking plus years.
I was talking to Gumi.
And like, she's like...
Bitch, why the fuck are you talking about Neopets?
And I was just like...
That's gonna be my first gaming stream.
And then she's like...
Oh my god.
Check out my private server Neopets account.
And that blew my fucking mind.
There's private server Neopets account?
Like...
And she was like...
Yeah, inflation fucking sucks on the public servers.
I was like...
What?
It got so bad...
That people had to make private servers...
Because the inflation fucking sucks.
And I was like...
Excuse me?
But I can finally do it.
I can finally stream Neopets.
Oh my god.
They brought back unconverted pets!
Do you guys know that?
Fun fact!
The unconverted pets are on the black market.
Where you actually have to pay real money.
Like thousands of dollars.
To own an unconverted pet.
And now the market fucking crashed.
Because now they're introducing it back.
Because the creators of...
Alright, okay.
I can say this now.
Because I don't have to tiptoe to lie.
But if you guys didn't know...
Neopets used to be owned by Scientology.
I can say that now.
Okay.
But they sold it.
They sold it.
And then they tried to be an NFT game.
And then they sold it to someone else.
And now...
Apparently...
The CEO of Neopets now...
Is actually like...
Some nostalgic old Neopets player.
He's like some fucking guy that grew up on Neopets.
Who's like some tech mongol now.
And he bought back Neopets.
And he's like, bring back unconverted pets!
Which I think it's because...
You know, he's like...
I have so much money now.
I don't wanna...
You know when you have...
Like a lot of money.
And then you're just like...
Give me back what the original version was.
So I can live my childhood now.
That type of deal.
You have so much money.
You buy back something and just revert it back to what it was.
Because that's where you had found happiness.
So like that's what he did.
And now...
The unconverted pets are back now.
So...
So like...
He brought back like...
Nostalgia just for himself.
Alright so like...
What I wanna do on Neopets...
Is I wanna enter the beauty contest.
Because I wanna fucking actually win...
First place in a beauty contest.
With the least amount of effort.
Because the beauty contest...
In Neopets taught me the hard thing.
Like taught me...
Fucking harsh reality.
Where it's not about how good you are at art.
It's basically a fucking popularity contest.
And who the fuck...
Advertises...
And who advertises on the beauty contest forums...
The most.
And all that.
I'll vote for you shit if you vote for me.
Now!
I'm a streamer.
So I can abu...
Now!
I can...
I can make you...
Vote for me.
I don't fucking work for that anymore.
So...
ROBLOX!
Someone said it!
I can finally do Warrior Cats Roleplay.
No!
You don't understand!
Warrior Cats Roleplay...
Is just something I wanted in this stream.
For fucking ever.
No!
Okay.
I know like... okay.
You never grew up with Warrior Cats.
Allright, now you read...
Okay.
When you get older...
You realize that this...
The books were pretty fucked up.
Because it was written by three different women.
I think I said girls.
It was written by three different women.
And there were so many fucking cats...
That they didn't even know what the fuck was going on anymore.
Because...
One book was written by three different women.
That it was so hard to remember what cat was what.
Because...
I felt like they're always making babies.
So like there's always new fucking cats.
So there's like a whole fucking Wikipedia of trying to figure out which cat is what.
Because there's so many.
There's like Ravenpaw 1 and Ravenpaw 2.
Ravenpaw 1 from FireClan and then Ravenpaw fucking 500 and ShadowClan and shit like that.
And you don't care!
Because all you care about is like three cats or some shit.
Like Firestar fucking something.
Anyway, sorry I...
Sorry I...
I got way too into it.
Yeah, Erenhunter is not one person.
It's three!
That blew my fucking mind.
And they always forget what cat was what.
Like if you... it's like a thing.
They're like who the fuck is like Shadowpelt or whatever.
Like was he the one that like... I don't know.
Was he the one that fucked that cat?
Oh, we don't know.
Oh, he has two dads now.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna...
I... I have a tangent and so...
I... I watched so many shorts.
I watched so many YouTube shorts.
I've gained so many knowledge on YouTube shorts.
That I... like while watching YouTube shorts, like fun fact...
Like there's like, you know, some YouTube shorts have like fun facts and shit like that.
I've like liked so many shorts.
So like I was like, whatever.
If I could ever stream...
If I could ever stream again...
I need to... I need to tell them...
The things I learned.
All the things I learned on the fucking internet.
I need to... I need to tell somebody.
And there's so many... much... I...
I swear I like wasted like 3-4 hours of my life just in my bed just watching YouTube shorts.
Because life was meaningless back then.
Doki, why are you laughing?
That sounded so fucking depressing.
Because if you don't laugh...
It gets too real.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Fuck, okay.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Wait.
Is the store ready?
Mr. Man?
Is the... Is the store ready?
If the store is ready, just send me the link, Mr. Man.
I don't even know if my manager is even watching me, to be honest.
Oh my god.
First day on the job!
Well, not... It wasn't his first day on the job.
But...
Guys, I have to message Mr. Man right now.
Alright.
Is the store ready?
Whoop!
There I go.
It's the shift key for those who are wondering why I keep doing that.
Why the fuck do I keep moving like this?
Alright.
Boop.
There we go.
Wait, what?
No.
No, that's not how I...
Oh my gosh.
Boop.
There we go.
Sorry.
So, wait.
I'm not even aligned.
Fuck.
Okay.
Boop.
I am such a mess.
I am...
I am such a fucking mess.
But I'm your mess.
What does this say about you guys for watching this?
Just feels so good to stream again.
I...
Oh my god.
It really...
Really.
It feels so good to stream again.
I...
I really miss this.
I really...
Okay, because I know Mr. Man isn't watching me.
He was like, did you look at the preview of the store?
And I said, yes.
But I actually didn't.
But it's okay.
He doesn't know, because he's not even watching me.
He's just like, okay, I'm gonna watch this.
So...
My first test...
Does my manager even watch my first fucking stream?
That's my very first test.
He doesn't know.
I don't... I think he's...
I don't... Wait.
Okay, wait.
He's typing.
He's the first one in the wild.
Mr. Man, are you even watching my very first stream?
Where I literally said, I didn't even check the preview.
And I said yes anyway.
Wait.
No.
No, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
No, he's not...
By the way, I don't think he's watching.
Because I fucking... I can say whatever the fuck I want to this guy.
And he doesn't know.
There we go.
Alright.
Because he was like...
Do you want the store to be in...
Canadian...
Canadian... Canadian dollars?
And I was like...
Fuck no.
The Canadian dollars suck.
What the fuck?
Why would it be Canadian dollars?
Canadians relate though.
Canadians relate.
We'd rather have American money.
Well, I'd rather have American money and then like, you know, fucking...
Even if we convert it back to Canadian money, it's still a lot more money.
Not wrong.
Give me that fucking sweet old American cash.
Not Canadian cash.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, we pay $90 for free fucking new video games.
That's the best part.
Oh my god!
No.
I hate this shit.
Alright.
Basically...
What was I gonna say?
Fuck!
Sorry.
It's been so long for me to talk...
That like, whenever I have something on my mind, it like disappears so fast now.
Because like, I'm so not... it's like not a routine anymore.
So it's so... I was like, yeah!
Idea!
And then my idea just... it's just no idea.
No...
No idea anymore.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking washed.
I'm so washed.
I like how people are still suggesting bad names.
They're like...
Okay.
Yeah.
You say that.
Anyway...
What about free birds?
Guys!
We're not...
We're not gonna be free birds.
Oh my god!
Okay.
So you know how...
I watched...
You know how I watched...
Twilight?
With my friend?
And...
I was like, what the fuck are we watching Twilight?
And she was like, no, you don't understand.
It's so good.
It's like...
Bad good.
And then...
Okay.
So I need to talk about this.
I need to talk about this.
So...
Thing is...
Like...
So the Collins family...
Alright.
The whole story is like...
I didn't realize how fuck...
How the cinematography is...
Honestly...
What the fuck was cinematography?
But...
Like...
The Collins...
Everyone is fucking their own sibling.
Sorry.
Banging their own...
I don't need to worry about that.
Anyway...
Banging their own sibling.
Like adopted sibling.
Except for...
Edward.
And like...
But then they're like the cool popular kids.
And then they're like the cool popular kids.
And I was like...
I swear to God.
What the fuck would you think like...
You're like...
Oh my God.
She's so cool.
She pink...
Her boyfriend is her adopted brother.
It's so fucking cool.
I'm like...
What the fuck?
What?
And...
And the thing is...
Like...
You know how the book is written by a Mormon?
Yeah.
And then...
So like...
So like for her...
It's like...
You know...
Oh...
Only after marriage...
You know...
It's like...
So like...
Because you know...
He's like...
No.
Only when we're married.
You know?
So like...
I'm thinking...
Because Edward is a hundred and something years old.
Right?
So he's like a hundred year...
And then I realized.
I said this...
I like...
Said this.
I said it out loud afterwards.
I was like, oh my god.
It was a fucking hundred year old version.
And then like my friend was just like so shocked I said that.
It didn't click in her head.
Because you know, he's never married.
He's a super wizard.
I was like... and then I... but then like the thing is...
Like one of his adopted siblings was like...
Was like, I don't like Bella.
Like I don't like Bella.
I don't want her near us.
She's a human.
But like I was like...
Bro.
Bro, he's...
He's just... let him have something.
You have your fucking adopted brother.
He has nothing.
For a hundred years.
I was like, bro.
She's like, no.
I want him to be...
Single forever.
I was like, that's so fucked up.
Anyway, also there's wolf puberty too.
For those who don't know wolf puberty...
Okay, so for the context for wolf puberty...
It's that...
The context of wolf puberty is that...
So there's a wolf tribe and like...
When you hit wolf puberty, you like beef the fuck up.
So like before... before you hit wolf puberty, you're like this fucking scrawny kid.
I read the first book of Twilight.
For those who don't know context wise...
I try to fit in.
And like at that time in my volleyball team...
And then everyone in my volleyball team read Twilight.
And then they were always like, are you in...
Are you team Edward or team Jacob?
So I wanted to fit in.
Because they would be on a fucking like doggy pile reading Twilight and shit like that.
So then I was like, oh shit.
Okay.
I need to fit in with these girls.
So I guess I'll read Twilight.
After I read like up to two books.
And then after that...
I still buy the books so I can bring it to practice.
But like when the book comes out...
When the newest book comes out...
I would go to like the Twilight Wikipedia and just read the wiki.
But I'll pretend to bring...
I'll bring the book to pretend that I read it.
So then they'll like ask me about the plot.
And then I'll just be like...
I'll just fucking...
I'll just remember the shit I read on Wikipedia.
So I didn't have to read the book.
Because...
I'm sorry but it was so bad.
It was so...
I was just like...
I just cliff note that shit.
Because like...
Anyway, in the book...
Jacob is like some fucking scrawny ass teenager or some shit.
But then he hits puberty.
And then he starts taking off his shirt.
And like gets like buffer.
The thing is...
The actor that plays Jacob...
Taylor...
Taylor Lawner...
By the way...
He marries...
His wife is also called Taylor Lawner.
And so they're Taylor and Taylor.
I don't fucking know...
I'm not...
I don't know what the fuck is going on with that scenario.
I don't know if that's like a fucking fetish or something.
But like...
It has to be.
Like I feel like it just has to be.
Like why the fuck would you...
Oh my god!
Who are you?
Taylor Lawner?
You're...
Oh my god!
What a coincidence!
Now I love you.
Anyway...
But like in the movies...
Jacob...
Jacob is like...
He looks...
He didn't get skinnier...
For the role.
They just put more clothes on him.
So he...
They just...
Like...
You can tell...
You can tell like...
He didn't want to force him to like...
Bulk up for the second movie.
So like...
You can tell that they're like...
How the fuck do we make him look like...
Uh...
Like a scrawny ass stick.
Let's just put like 500 layers of clothes on him.
And give him long hair.
To hide his like fucking muscle or some shit.
And then like when he hits wolf puberty...
Let's just give...
Make him shirtless and cut his hair.
So it looks like...
He hit wolf puberty.
So...
That's a little fun fact.
I wanted...
Also...
Yes, I'll confirm...
That she was like...
Here comes the next best part!
And then she literally was like...
Spider monkey!
I was just like...
What the fuck?
We have scuba diving here.
We literally watched...
We also like...
Well...
Yeah...
We watched live action Pinnochio.
Just like...
I was like...
I was just like you...
I told her I was like...
Oh, no.
You don't understand.
Like...
The live action Disney movies are a...
And she's never really watched live action Disney movies.
So like...
Like that is THE luck I have I found.
Sometimes I wonder if I shouldN .
I... Live Action Pinocchio... Okay, you know how like the reviews for Live Action Pinocchio...
Like... It's like fucking, I don't know, like 20% or some shit.
I don't... I can't... I don't really know the numbers on top of my head.
But then you're like, it can't be that bad.
Like how... how can you fuck up?
There's... Tom Hanks is in there.
Like how... how...
How does that work?
Literally... Tom Hanks is in there.
And...
The thing is...
It...
We... we like watched, I think...
15 minutes of Live Action Pinocchio.
And we're like...
Alright, let's pop in real Pinocchio.
Like this is...
I...
It's... it's...
Oh my god.
It is...
Like... Tom Hanks cannot save that...
Fucking... movie.
We... we only kept watching... for the fox.
Because we want... because like I was like, no... the fox... the... the... the 3D...
No, you don't understand the 3D animation for the fox.
For some fucking reason, they cut 90% of the budget for the main character Pinocchio.
And then put it all on the fucking fox.
Because why the fuck does he... the fox look like that...
And then you look at Pinocchio.
The fox is on... is on like 600 frames.
The fox is on...
is on like 600 frames.
Per second.
And Pinocchio is like, I don't know...
Fox is like...
4080 RTX on.
Pinocchio is like... Flash games.
And I don't understand.
Like that... that... that is the... the...
That is the craziest part of all of that.
Alright.
I'm gonna ask for...
I'm gonna ask for the fucking...
For the fucking story.
I'm gonna ask for the store update real quick.
How...
How is the store update?
I swear to God.
I...
I don't understand.
Pinocchio is the main character.
Um...
Anyway, that's what I was saying.
Uh...
What are my plans for next week?
I definitely wanna do like...
I definitely wanna play Neopets.
For the first gaming stream.
And then I wanna line up a bunch of collabs.
Uh... going in.
And...
I... I feel like a lot of you guys...
might have this question.
Meaning like...
Oh!
Uh...
What are some of your events you wanna plan?
Um...
One of the events I really, really, really wanna do...
Is a big...
A big...
Wrestling event.
With a lot of different...
Indies and...
And...
Vtuber companies.
In NA.
I think it'll be really fun!
I think it'll be really fun.
And...
Um...
I really wanna order...
Uh...
Some...
Enamel pins.
To give out to everybody who participates as well.
It'll be...
I think that...
That's definitely some future plans that I really wanna do.
Some projects that I really wanna do.
I really wanna organize...
Uh...
Some mini...
Um...
Some tournaments.
Like...
For different games.
Uh...
And stuff.
And...
Uh...
With prizes and everything.
And trophies.
Um...
And physical trophies.
I think it'll be really fun!
I think like...
The most fun events are the ones that you can be super creative about.
And...
Uh...
Have like...
Something to cheer on for.
Uh...
Yeah that's like some of the projects and events...
I really want to plan out...
In a call, give me five...
No!
Mr... Okay.
Leave that call.
I wonder if Mr. Man would take that seriously or not.
He's not even watching the first stream anyway.
He doesn't fucking know if I'm serious or not.
Okay.
Open store.
Okay, I'll just write JK.
I want to do escape rooms.
I want to do like...
Minecraft escape rooms.
And like...
Pit people against each other.
That shit would be so fun.
And then you'd be like...
Oh my god, which...
Which...
And then you guys can like...
Cheer on for like...
Which team...
Of our team and stuff like that.
That would be so fucking fun.
I feel like there's not a lot of like...
Um...
Like there's a lot of like...
MCC for like...
Minecraft content creators.
But you don't see like...
A lot of MCC for like...
Vtubers as well.
So I want to do like a Vtuber MCC.
Plan a Vtuber type MCC and stuff.
With like mini games.
And everything.
Because like...
Oh my god, I can do so many things.
I can do so many plans.
And projects.
And...
Uh...
League games.
Obviously Apex.
Of course, of course.
Uh...
I actually do have like...
An Apex...
Tournament.
That I'm working on.
With some best...
Some besties.
Hahaha.
So...
That's something to look forward to as well.
Um...
That's right!
We're still the besties!
Hahaha.
We're still there!
Um...
And...
Honestly, like I said, there's so many ideas.
Um...
I'm really excited to plan all of that.
With...
Uh...
With my manager.
And...
I cannot wait.
I really cannot wait.
I...
I cannot wait!
I cannot wait.
I cannot wait to get started.
I...
I'm so excited.
Honestly.
Uh...
Oh yeah.
For those who don't know what MCC is.
It's like the Minecraft Championship.
But usually it's like something you see for Minecrafters.
Like Minecraft content creators.
But honestly, I haven't seen one of those.
I really want to do like...
I feel like a lot of tournaments and a lot of events.
They're like always regulated into like one...
One company.
Like...
I think it'd be really fun to have like an...
Uh...
A company wide...
Oh!
Like team indies and like...
And like...
Like...
Like different...
Different like companies and NA...
Uh...
Participating and stuff.
And like fan bases from different areas.
Like watching.
I think that would be really fun.
I really think.
Cause you always see like tournaments and events usually from one...
One company.
I think it'd be really cool to have like...
Uh...
To set something up where people from different companies can participate and stuff.
So...
Yeah!
I want to do something like that.
Alright!
Okay!
I see it.
Pow world.
I'm gonna say it!
After you play like three days of Pow World non-stop...
Like you...
It's...
That's it.
I'm gonna fucking say it!
You realize!
It's...
It's fun.
But like...
When you hit three days of Pow World...
You hit a point where you're like...
Alright.
I realize.
After three days...
It's like the same thing.
It's like...
And like...
Honestly like it just needs like more...
Uh...
Intuitiveness.
It needs more updates to keep me interested.
But like the thing about Pow World...
The thing about Pow World is that like...
Um...
It is very fun.
It's a very fun unique concept and...
Honestly like...
That's what we need.
Like I wish we had that in other similar...
Wait I can say it now.
In Pokemon!
Sorry my inner filter fucking killed me.
I'm kicked in.
Because I liked...
Like...
It was Pokemon Legends Arceus or whatever.
That one.
Was that...
Was that one?
I really liked that one.
I really really liked that game.
And...
Um...
I wish...
Uh...
I wish Pokemon can be similar as well.
The fucking...
Mr. Man.
I cannot stall Mr. Man.
Wait I...
Why did I type Mr. Man?
I know like...
I cannot stall...
Anymore.
Give me a story.
But yeah.
I think like streaming...
Is...
A great...
It's just...
When you start streaming, I don't know, streaming always makes me a lot happier.
And when I couldn't stream, I felt so empty.
Oh my god.
I felt... I've been in a routine for so long that when...
when you suddenly stop streaming, it's just...
It's like, what do I do with my life at that point?
Because you've been in this routine for so... so fucking long.
And it just makes me so happy being able to just stream and laugh with you guys.
And talk about the dumbest fucking thing.
Just have fucking people enable the shit.
Or other people enable the shit.
And just have fucking people enable the shit.
And I think my therapist was right when he was like, Oh, you seem very different now.
After, compared to the other times.
Oh my god.
Compared to the other times, I'm fucking...
Oh fuck man.
It was like, yeah, you seem very...
Very different.
And you actually seem like you...
You have a purpose in life again.
And he's right.
He's right.
I felt like I have a purpose and I have...
I'm a very goal-oriented person.
And being a very goal-oriented person...
I always like to plan the next thing.
To do something and everything.
To always...
To always just...
I just always want to do something.
I always want to keep my mind busy.
So it's nice because my mind has been like...
Chugga chugga choo choo for...
For the last two days.
And honestly, I...
It's nice to be busy again.
It's nice to have stuff to do.
I really do need to fix my sleep schedule though.
Holy shit, my sleep schedule is fucking horrendous.
I haven't had a normal sleep schedule.
In so long.
I tried to fix it for a while.
But it hasn't been working.
Because I've been a degenerate for so long.
Back to back to back to back.
That...
That like...
It...
Honestly, I'm just...
Oh my god.
It's just gonna take a bit to rebuild myself.
But it really...
It really, really is...
All right, let me read you...
Sorry, Mr. Man.
I'm gonna read your messages.
I'll do all these people.
These extra stuff, ma'am.
Domain and whatnot.
So like...
I'm making sure there's no potential security issues.
Ria and Intu.
Open the...
Okay, no, actually we'll be so fucked up.
So fucked up.
I opened the floodgates and then I...
Whoa, whoa, Doki got hacked.
And I was like, what?
How?
What?
You mean me rushing Mr. Man to open the store and not looking to safety precautions?
Actually made me get hacked?
Whoa, really?
No way.
This is what it means to be an indie?
Actual concern about website security?
What the fuck?
Also so for those who don't know.
There is going to be a limited...
So like...
There's gonna be new things for the merch.
I've added some new stuff there.
For one, I added a limited bundle of the rock...
What is it?
Sorry, rock...
Robbank bundle.
And it's only limited to like 100 stock.
And...
It's only limited to 100 stock.
And it has a...
A...
Signed postcard.
Like hand signed postcard from me.
Plus like a...
I think...
I think that's right.
I don't remember what I wrote.
I guess so...
I don't know.
I've...
I haven't...
Oh my god, no.
Wait.
Okay.
So like I'm so fucked with the Etsy.
There's so many orders.
Thank you guys so much for the support.
Thank you everybody.
I...
But also I'm so fucked.
I have 200 plus orders.
Oh my god.
Um...
To like my mom and I to package and everything.
There's 200 plus orders for my mom and I to package.
And...
Uh...
Can you be...
No, what the fuck?
Can it be signed by Mr. Man?
What the fuck?
You met Mr. Man today!
Like what?
What?
What the fuck do you mean?
Someone's like, that's all I need.
One day is all I need for Mr. Man.
Um...
Uh...
Wait, give me a sec.
All right.
No, you can put yours.
Okay.
Um...
But anyway...
Uh...
I was like, do you want this?
And I was like, uh, yeah.
And he's like, oh, I was doing it anyway.
Just asked to be polite, but he already did it.
Um...
But yes, for the limited bundle, it'll be 100 for a sign, an extra bonus signed postcard.
And then, um...
Um...
I guess I can spoil you guys for what the Lunar New Year merch is gonna be.
So we're gonna have the acrylic stand.
Um...
And a...
Oh, okay.
So like, I tell you, I used to do artist alley.
So I actually have a button, those button makers.
And...
Woo!
They pay...
It's a lot of work.
I actually hand make those buttons.
So we're gonna have those like pin back buttons.
Because I actually really like hand making them because they're really fun.
Because they're like, boom, boom.
Like they're really fun to do.
Um...
But yes, it's gonna have the...
Those button...
Pin back buttons for the Lunar New Year merch.
And like those like little...
Not little, sorry.
Those cushions.
Like the...
Uh...
Those cushions and stuff.
Like the...
Uh...
There's like gonna be a cushion.
And also...
Also, we're gonna have the red pocket envelope.
Which is my favorite.
My favorite part about all of this.
I'm so excited.
You should buy the red pocket envelope.
To give it to...
Whoever's married.
So they can use that to give money to you.
It pays itself.
You know?
Or...
Send the link to whoever is like to all your married friends, relatives, and like parents.
And it'd be like, I will only accept your money if you use a Doki Bird envelope.
You don't have to pay for the envelope.
And...
You get the embo...
And you get like extra money too.
So it's like, you know, free shit.
So...
That's it.
That's Lifehack.
But only for like anyone that celebrates Lunar New Year.
Lifehack.
Oh yes.
For those who are wondering.
Is YouTube gonna be my main platform?
YouTube will be my main pla...
I like how this...
This is not even...
This is not infor...
This was not an informative stream.
This is not an informative stream.
It's like, hey, Doki's back.
She's gonna fucking explain a lot of stuff and then...
And then all that stuff, information.
And then here I am talking about Roblox, Worry Cats and fucking all that other shit.
In between.
It's like going through 30 minutes of ads before you get to the what you want type deal.
It's like, if you wanna learn more, go through the 30 minute ads of fucking Roblox, Worry Cats RP.
No skipping!
Wow!
Ad block doesn't work here!
Anyway, after I said all of that, I actually forgot what I was trying to...
Oh yes, main platform.
Main platform will be YouTube.
And I will also...
I will also...
Be planning on...
I will be planning on streaming on Twitch.
As well as...
Bilibili.
So...
But it's not gonna be like...
It's just like, you know, in the past.
It's not like a common thing being on...
On those two sites.
You know the best part?
Okay, I'm gonna wanna see...
I'm also gonna be very curious if like...
Because like...
My old Twitch account...
I've already hit like partner requirements.
And...
No, it's not gonna be a simulcast.
I don't like that.
I don't...
I personally...
I personally don't like...
Oh my god!
Kitto?
I don't even guys remember Kitto.
But she actually reached out...
And said she'd help me with...
With making...
With making an account.
So...
So I really appreciate it too.
But yes, anyway, what was I gonna say?
My Twitch!
I've actually hit Twitch partner...
Long long long ago.
And...
I never got it.
Because all I did was send in...
The B-movie script.
Oh Doki, maybe you stop sending the fucking B-movie script...
To the Twitch staff.
Maybe you would have got Twitch partner.
So...
I was...
I think I applied like three to four times or something.
I got rejected every time.
Because I...
All I did was just send in the B-movie script to them.
Repeatedly.
Yes.
And so...
Because of that...
They rejected me like three to four times.
And...
But!
I still am eligible to reapply.
So I was thinking...
Well...
If I do one stream on it...
Maybe we'll take it.
I don't even know how much money is missing...
I only have three B -movie scripts.
And then I have to re-release it.
I'm like...
I'm dead.
I don't think I'm getting more than the B-movie script.
But I think I'll have to wait for it.
Because I'm going to have to wait...
It's hard to get this much...
I need to...
I think it's going to be...
I think...
Around...
It's over.
How am I so stupid?
Remember when I was like, I stop looking at my bank account when I'm spending money?
What the fuck was wrong with me?
I just really... I just... I just wanna have fun with all of you guys.
And I always wanted to... I love doing it!
Okay, anyway, sorry.
Sorry I got into... I got way too...
That fucked me up.
I'm sorry.
It's like a little... It's like a trigger for me every time.
Every time I think about it, I... It doesn't make me angry.
It makes me... I... You're so fucking stupid.
I'm just like...
I was like, you didn't make any profit.
I was like...
That... That just... That fucked me up.
That actually...
That... That actually... That actually fucked me up.
I keep finding that out.
Oh my god.
Mr. Matt, what the fuck is the website?
I talked for like...
Two hours!
This has been a two hour fucking ad!
A two hour unskippable ad.
This site sucks.
I just bought the sub, but it won't let me buy it.
We don't need the... Go live!
We don't need the domain.
We'll get the domain later!
We can always get the domain later!
We'll figure it out later.
Anyway, cat escape.
Mr. Matt is doing his best.
Do he please understand?
Don't worry, he likes it.
If I know my chat...
It's fine.
Is that how... What?
Okay, I swear to god, if I put a poll right now...
And I was like...
Do you want me to yell at you?
I swear to god, like...
I know people be like...
No, don't let her win!
Don't let her get whatever she wants.
I swear to god, you guys would still vote yes.
Like 100%.
You know if I get a poll.
I'll be like...
Do you want Doki to yell at you?
And then...
You guys would be like...
Oh my god, yes.
That should be me!
Mr. M.
Do you want Doki to yell at you?
Alright, here we go.
I...
Like, you can't deny that.
True!
She's like...
I'm doing it.
No, I don't.
My ears would hurt.
Yeah, but like...
It's like...
You know, it's like that, you know?
I won't say it though.
That's okay.
That's what the poll is for.
That's what it's for.
Alright, guys.
It's gonna be scuffed.
But like...
The store...
When it goes live...
It does not have a custom domain.
But I just wanted to put the store...
I just wanted to put the store...
We'll fix it later.
We'll fix this...
I had two days.
It's great!
I can always use that excuse for everything I do now.
I can always use that excuse.
I had two days.
So...
We will...
We will fix it in post.
Do not worry.
Do not...
The store is gonna go live and chat is gonna instantly...
Yeah, I've never...
Okay.
Honestly, like...
I...
I like...
Pre-ordered like...
50 because...
I don't...
I didn't...
Okay.
When my...
When my therapist was like...
How many people are you expecting to watch?
And I was just like...
Oh...
I don't know.
I think maybe like...
If it's gonna be really high...
It might be like 50k.
Like...
Maybe I think...
Because of, you know...
All that stuff that happened.
And then he's like...
Wow!
So then I was like...
How many people will buy merch if 50k people are gonna watch me?
I'll pre-order 50k.
In my mind, I was like...
Okay.
If 50k people are gonna watch me...
That means 50 people would want merch.
So...
I'm like...
I already...
In advance...
Because there was like a Lunar New Year discount.
There was a Lunar...
Lunar New Year discount at this manufacturer.
Because like I'm handling all the manufacturing shit.
All that stuff.
And like...
Coordinating all that stuff.
So...
So I was like...
They're like...
Oh, how much you wanna wait?
And I was like...
50k.
That seems like a lot of people that will buy my merch.
And I was just like...
Yeah.
And now I'm like...
Now I'm a little worried.
Because now I'm like...
Oh no.
What if...
What if 50k is just a little bit too...
Too little.
Just a little bit under.
Just...
Oh man.
Maybe 50 is just...
You know...
Just a little bit under.
So...
Don't worry.
That's why it's a preorder so I can order more.
It's a preorder so I won't...
Now I know not to order in advance.
Because I'm just gonna go by preorders for this.
So like do not worry about that.
Because it will be going by preorders.
So...
It's not like I only have 50k.
50 in stock.
Maybe...
You know, I don't know.
Maybe I'll get 60.
Whoa.
That would be fucking insane.
Holy shit.
Maybe 60 people will buy my merch.
But...
Don't worry.
It's uncapped except for the limited edition bundle.
Where the signed postcards.
That is capped to a hundred.
Because...
A hundred is the limit.
I will...
Sign...
A postcard.
Um...
Because...
That is a lot of postcards.
That is...
That is just, you know, a little...
That's a lot.
That's just so a lot.
And I really... I don't really want to get...
Oh, what's it called when you fuck up your wrists?
Carpal tunnel?
Yeah, I really don't want to get carpal tunnel.
Because, you know, I play FPS shooters.
And like, carpal tunnel is...
Where FPS players die.
So...
If I...
Oh, I shouldn't say that.
No!
Wait, no, I shouldn't.
That's... I shouldn't.
I go to therapy now.
I'm okay.
I couldn't...
You know, sometimes you gotta be able to laugh.
Sometimes you gotta be able to laugh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Anyway.
Um...
Uh...
Mr. Matt, what the fuck?
Where?
We're not Freebirds!
I swear...
We can come up with better names!
Freebirds is a fucking...
Okay, I'm gonna say it.
It's a good song.
But it's...
You can make it your fucking national anthem if you want.
But we're not gonna be called Freebirds.
Because...
Look.
I've been in this game for a while now.
Okay?
Like, we've came up with a solid name.
Last time.
We can do it again.
I know what makes a good name.
But like, Freebirds is not a good...
Free...
Like, it's not a good fan mascot name.
We can do better!
I know we can!
I know.
You just...
Do you see a...
A bot that says like, three to four years?
Like, what the fuck do you mean?
I wanna be the Doki Prokis.
You know what the...
What the fuck?
We had two days.
Alright.
We're not gonna be Freebirds!
I swear to fucking god, we're not...
Wait, no, that's not...
No, I was gonna say Chirpians.
There's...
It's pretty clever.
But like, it's...
It's...
It's not as pretty.
No.
If you say it out loud...
If you say it out loud, it's not the best...
The best name.
It's cool to read it.
The Bird Brigade.
Oh, look at that!
Do you want Doki to yell at you?
Yes.
83% yes.
And then people who are saying no are those who are fucking in denial.
Alright, that's cool.
I told you guys.
I know you guys are fucking freaks.
You're my freak.
But...
Alright, do it for f- Oh shit, it's live.
What the fuck is the URL?
Okay.
That's on me.
Alright, so you guys know.
It says opening soon.
What...
Okay.
Alright.
So, you guys know.
Okay.
Guys.
Guys!
Okay, when you see the URL It's like the theme of this entire... my journey here today.
It's actually this fucking theme.
This theme of my very first stream.
Okay, let me say...
Opening soon?
Question mark!
Sorry, I had to shimmy to the left again.
Okay, let me refresh and see if that helps.
But when you see the URL of this store, it is...
You will understand where we're at in life.
You know, I feel it just fits where I'm at in life right now.
Like, how I've been feeling the past month.
Honestly, it's it's like we're there.
We're there.
We made it.
We're existing.
It's... it's happening.
Why does it say opening soon?
I like how it wrote opening soon and then silence.
Silence.
Alright, give me a sec.
Why is it called Dokieworks.
Oh, cause we don't have... we don't have our own domain.
Dokiemons?
chu?
Go.
Go!
Do... vibes.
Doki mayo.
Dokiemoins!
No!
Because I don't want you guys to be called Dokie.
I thought about it, but like... no!
No no no no no!
I literally renamed my dog!
I literally gave him a nickname!
You're not taking Doki from me!
Alright?
I renamed him to Doki Amber Doge.
So like, you're not taking Doki from me.
Yeah, I gave him Dad.
Chirp Knights.
Oh my god.
Come here Chirp Knight.
No.
I can't say that.
Chirp Knights.
No, it just doesn't...
It's so hard!
It's so hard finding like, the perfect name.
It really is.
Wingman.
Yeah, but then like Tricking!
Then you'd be...
It's like...
I don't wanna fucking...
I don't wanna draw...
a grown ass man.
Hahahaha!
It's just like the most detailed, like, macho man out there.
Cause like, that's what I...
Hahahaha!
Uh...
Let's see...
The back seaters.
Bro, who said...
Hahahaha!
No, Wing... Yeah, I'm not...
You guys are not gonna be...
Get the mascot!
Man!
The mascot will just be one man, please.
Man standing still.
Welcome...
No, we're not doing Freebirds!
Hello, Freebirds.
No, it's so stupid!
Hahahaha!
Birdseed...
Oh my god.
Why are your names so hard?
This is like...
my third time doing this.
Why?
I should be...
Oh, I should be better at...
There's more of you now!
There's more of you!
Surely there should be more ideas!
That's how fucking group work works!
Oh no, actually, group works is the more there is, there's...
The more people there are, the more people that's just gonna make one person do all the work.
Uh...
You're not gonna be little tomatoes.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna just squish you.
Um...
Free...
...
No.
Because apparently...
Zoomers ruined the word goons now, so...
...
What was it?
Yeah, I heard that...
I saw like people started...
Zoomers did some... Not Zoomers.
What was it?
Um...
What are the ones after Zoomers now?
What are they?
Z?
Wait... Who... What... I mean...
Sorry, Zoomers... Who... Who... What's after?
What's after Zoomers?
Already... It's been a while.
...
Gen Alpha?
I heard Gen Alpha ruined... Gen Alpha ruined goons, so...
We cannot have...
We cannot have that in there anymore.
We cannot have that.
Anymore.
Alright.
Mr. Man, I swear.
Mr. Man is having the fucking hardest time opening up the store.
...
He's like...
He's like, why is it so hard?
No, it says opening soon!
...
He's like...
Okay, so what's going on is that...
What's going on is that...
We solve one problem...
And then...
It leads to another problem...
And then we solve that problem... And then it goes...
... to another problem...
...
He's just like, why?
Why?
It's still opening soon!
What do you want from me?
Bird Knights?
Okay, I actually thought about Bird Knights...
But like, it's...
Not a great name when you say it.
...
When you say it out loud.
Bird Knights.
Because like, you can't say Bird Knights very...
Like, if you say Bird Knights very fast...
It's like...
It sounds... That's what I'm saying!
Getting the perfect name...
Is like...
Who the fuck said...
Nesticle?
What the fuck are you?
I don't have members, so now it's...
... harder to find people.
Now it... Hooters.
My Hooters.
Fuck!
No!
Wait, no!
No, don't be tempted.
No, sorry.
That actually... That's...
...
Welcome to the... Welcome to the...
Welcome Hooters.
No.
No, we shouldn't be.
I can't.
It's funny, but... It's...
It's funny, but we can't be Hooters, guys.
As much as...
... we can have transformative work now...
... we cannot be Hooters.
That...
That would...
... not be ideal...
... for...
... Deagles...
... is good because of the...
...
... Doki Bark?
Oh my god!
I would...
... Okay, I was so fucking...
... I would say I was very clever, but like...
... I would... Okay, so like...
... So, my Twitch...
... tag, like the...
... the emote, like... stuff...
... you have... It's like Doki Bee.
So then, I had like... I would actually...
... make real words out of it, like...
... Doki Bark.
Doki Bang.
... Which is like Doki with a gun.
... Doki Bread.
...
... I would have like real...
... I would just make real words out of my...
... emote, like... emote names and stuff.
... I love Doki Bang.
... Doki Bang is like one of my...
... Also like... Okay, we're gonna have...
... real emotes, but back then...
... I just... Back then...
... All I did was just... I took a picture...
... of my dog, and then I just drew...
... expressions on...
...
... I was a very low effort streamer.
... Oh my god, I was very...
...
... I took a picture of my dog...
... and then I just drew like expressions...
... on top of it, and like...
... Photoshop like items on...
... the emote.
... And then my sub badges was just...
... me drawing the sub badges in Emma's...
... Paint.
And then I just...
... snip... I just crop...
... crop it, and then I just...
... upload it.
And then sometimes you can see my...
... cursor on the sub badge.
... And the sub badges would be like the default sub badges...
... but like Emma's Paint.
... And then...
... That's why...
... I never thought I would get...
... this many people to watch me...
... because holy fuck...
... I was so lazy.
...
... Holy fuck...
... I...
... I was... I did not care.
... I didn't...
... I just... all I cared was...
... to talk to... I just wanted to talk to people.
... That's all I cared.
... This is why...
... I never got Twitch Partner for...
... fucking five... four times...
... after applying for four... three or...
... four times... this is why I never...
... got Twitch Partner.
...
... We're not nesticles!
... Jesus Christ!
... We're not gonna be...
... nesticles.
Alright, we're gonna...
... we're gonna shimmy to the... I'll fix...
... this later.
I'm gonna shimmy...
... to the left a little bit.
... You know what?
Fuck this.
Mr. Mad...
... How long do you think it's gonna take?
... How long... do you...
... think it's... This has been a...
... two hour plus ad.
...
... This has been a...
... two hour plus ad...
... that was unskippable...
... for 90,000 people.
...
... It's been 80...
... hooligans?
... No, wait...
... I feel like someone's hooligan...
... No, not that...
... Wing...
... Aviators...
...
... Best ad ever...
... Nightingale... OH MY GOD!
NIGHTINGALE!
... Oh, there's so many syllables.
Nightingales...
... Nightingales... Hello, my nightingale...
... Nah, sorry, that's way too...
... Uhhhh...
...
... At this point, I don't know...
... I think there's some info that might...
... take time to...
... process...
... What?
...
... Wait!
... Why can't we...
... Why can't we not have a domain?
... Okay, why...
... Why do we...
... need a domain?
... Just go and...
...
... He's like...
... Because the thing won't update...
... in my billing info...
...
... Okay, guys... guys...
... Most likely the shop might not go...
... The shop might not go live today...
... Apparently...
... Because we're in...
... It's been rough...
... But I'll show you guys the fucking...
... URL...
... Because it's so fucking...
... It's so funny...
... I saw the URL and I was just like...
... What the fuck?
... Oh my god...
... Look at this...
... Look at this URL...
... It doesn't show up...
... The header doesn't show up...
... Because it's not...
... Live...
... He's like...
... Can you please show your chat...
... The header that I worked so hard on...
... And I can't see it...
... Because...
... Okay...
... They will see it when the shop...
... Look, he's watching my stream...
... They will see it when the shop is live...
... Anyway...
... It's not live...
... But this is what the shop URL is...
... Because we couldn't buy the domain...
...
... I was just like...
... What the fuck?
... What the fuck is that?
... Okay, here we go...
... Look at my URL...
... Truly...
... Dude...
... This is why I'm an indie now...
...
... You can tell...
... I'm an indie...
... With this professional URL...
...
... It's opening soon by the way...
... Soon TM...
...
... Not the Shopify...
... Ah yes...
... Thank you...
... What do you mean...
... Fuck...
... I delegated the task to you...
...
... You cannot drag me into this...
... I delegated this task...
... To you...
... Oh my god...
... Okay, to be fair...
... We did not expect...
... So many...
... We did...
... Okay, to be fair...
... We did not expect so many emails...
... That Google locked my business account...
... Because there were too many emails...
... Who the fuck expects that...
... Like I've...
... Never had that happen to me before...
... There were so many emails...
... That Google just locked it...
... So it never...
... So then I had to change it to like...
... His personal email...
... Like...
... Cause they were like...
... What the fuck is wrong with your email account...
... Is it a bot...
... And I'm like... Oh fuck...
... Oh my...
... I did not expect so many things...
... And also...
... Guys, I'm sorry...
... I saved the website...
... Cause we can't get it...
... We couldn't launch it...
... We couldn't...
... I don't think I can launch it...
... I really don't think I can launch it...
... By the end of the stream...
... Because this has been...
... This...
...
... This has took a very long time...
... To try and get to work...
... But...
... When...
... I'm not gonna play a game...
... I'm not gonna play...
...
... That's my first...
... I said the first game I'm gonna do...
... I'm not gonna play Neopets right now...
... I said the very first game I'm gonna do...
... I'm playing Neopets...
... I'm not...
... Oh my god...
... My manager literally told me to watch...
... This...
... He told me to watch TikTok...
... Like... What the fuck...
...
... Okay...
... Alright...
... We need to figure it out...
... Figure it out Mr. Manager...
...
... Alright...
... We'll figure this out after the stream...
...
... And then...
... I'll tweet it out...
... When it goes live...
... And...
... Oh that sucks for you guys...
... There's like a hundred of the limited stock thing...
... And like...
... I feel like you guys are gonna...
... Oh my gosh...
... Okay...
... You guys might try to fight for it...
... So...
... We'll try not...
... We'll try and give you guys a heads up...
... Before it actually goes live...
... I feel like now that I gave the...
... Okay no...
... Cause we might change the domain later on...
... Cause I was like thinking like...
... Oh no... Now you guys are gonna camp the domain...
... And refresh my lovely...
... 43d9b2-2 domain...
...
... My love...
... You guys are gonna refresh...
... The 43d9b2-2 domain...
... Like...
... Link just to see...
... Whenever it does go up...
...
... So...
... Thank you...
... It's a beautiful name...
... Oh...
... Oh my gosh...
... Oh my fucking god...
... What a...
... Alright...
... I think it's serious time...
... It's serious time...
... Okay...
... It's the serious time hour now...
... Alright...
... Okay...
... I actually pre-wrote this...
... I pre-wrote this statement...
... Um...
... Anyway...
... Alright...
... I have to be serious now...
... It was nice just...
... You know...
... Hang out and just...
... Um...
... But this is the...
... I only talk about this once...
... And...
... And then we...
... Move forward!
... And celebrate Lunar New Year and new beginnings...
... Ah!
Okay...
... Ah... Okay...
... I'm just gonna read this...
...
... Okay... So...
... As you all know...
... When the announcement dropped...
... I was just as surprised as all of you...
... And...
... Um...
... I only found out because a friend messaged me...
... And...
... I didn't even know what was in it...
... And I read it for the first time...
... When it went public...
... Um...
... When I still know that I did try to leave neutral...
... Because I knew...
... It would be very bad for everyone involved...
... If it went to the last possible route...
... And...
... Um...
... And I tried...
... I really did try to make it neutral...
... And I did get a lawyer...
... Because...
... My emergency contact and I...
... Couldn't really handle it anymore...
... Uh... Especially when I was still recovering...
... And...
... I was lucky...
... That I had a statement made...
... In advance...
... Uh... Which my lawyer helped edit...
... In case this did happen...
... So I could respond instantly...
... Uh...
... The statement that was posted...
... Was written...
... So I would be safe...
... And I can move forward...
... And restart my life...
... While being stuck in limbo forever...
... And...
... I...
... Wouldn't have made the statement...
... If the announcement...
... Didn't go up the way it did...
... And...
... I was willing to keep...
... The info hidden to the public...
... And I never truly wanted the public to know...
... Why I was in the hospital...
... But...
... I had to respond with the truth...
... When it did...
... Went out...
... And I know there's a lot of people...
... That wish for me to clarify...
... Or explain more...
... But I honestly can't...
... And I'm sorry...
... And these are the things...
... That I can say...
... Though...
... I was in the hospital for an attempt...
... And I provided medical documents...
... Of everything that happened...
... To prove it as well...
... As the therapy sessions afterwards...
... And doctor evaluation...
... Everyone knew I was in the hospital...
... And the reason behind it...
... A few days before I was discharged...
... And I was not referencing something...
... That happened once...
... That pushed me to it...
... But it was a build up...
... That stemmed...
... For multiple months...
... That led to my breaking point...
... I would never make this claim...
... Without proof...
... Or confirmation...
... And only did so...
... That my lawyer looked through the proof...
... And believed and agreed...
... It was happening...
... For the multiple months...
... From what I showed...
... I honestly wish I could have met you all...
... One last time...
... And I cried when I found that I couldn't...
... And I hope I can still meet you all in the future...
... Even...
... If I would be a little different...
... My final note on all of this...
... Is...
... Let's not harass...
... Or bully anybody...
... I already know how that felt...
... And I want us to be adults...
... And not make it high school...
... And...
... I want to move on...
... Focus on us...
... Succeed and be better...
... And the Lunar New Year is coming...
... And it's two new beginnings...
... And it's time to leave...
... The past behind us...
... And make new memories...
... And...
... Like this entire stream...
... I have...
... So many ideas I still want to do...
... And I really do want to make all of you laugh...
... For as long as I can...
... And...
...
And...
... I think from this entire stream...
... You guys can tell...
... That...
... I'm still me...
... And they can never really take that away...
... So yeah...
... That was the statement...
... That I wrote...
... For this stream...
... And...
... The two hour ad is finally over...
... I think that's like...
... The...
... A huge weight...
... Off my shoulder...
... And...
... It's time...
... To move forward...
... And...
... Celebrate Lunar New Year...
... Yeah... I mean we can celebrate it early...
...
... Alright...
... Where is it?
...
... Alright when you were a little kid...
... Your parents... fucking relatives would always force you to...
... Do that fucking song...
... And just be like...
... Look at how cute they are...
... And then you do it because you're a greedy fuck...
... That wants more red pocket envelope...
... Because when you're a kid...
... You celebrate Lunar New Year...
... I think it's just an Asian thing maybe...
... We had...
... We were given forward about the harsh reality of money...
... As a very young age...
... Um...
... But yeah...
... I... I... I need...
... I know like it was a very serious statement...
... But I still wanna...
... Laugh with all of you...
... I still wanna make jokes...
... Because if I don't make these jokes...
... Then...
... Then it just gets too real...
...
... Then...
... We're here to... you know...
... We're...
... Life is short...
... And...
... I have hope for the future now...
... Thank you everybody...
... You guys don't have a name yet...
... So I don't know what to call you guys...
... Anyway...
...
... Thank you everybody...
... I enjoyed...
... Uh...
... I really did...
... I really enjoyed today's stream...
... Just talking with all of you...
... Um...
... All over again...
... And...
... Let's get to 500k subscribers...
... By the end of the year...
... Yeah!
... That's my wish...
... I just realized...
...
... Oh my god Doki...
... July 4th is your birthday...
... That's like 2 birthdays...
...
... If you think about it...
... ...
... Your birthday came back so fast...
...
... Wooo...
... Isn't that great?
... Alright...
... Um...
... How do we know that's your real birthday...
... This time?
... We fucked up if that wasn't even my real birthday...
... And I was just like...
... I want my birthday fast...
...
... Um...
... But yes everybody...
... As always everybody...
... Say hi...
... Posture check...
... Get up and move around to get that blood flowing...
... And if you stay up for me...
... Head to bed...
... Cause you deserve it...
... I'll see you guys next time everybody...
... Byeeeeee...
...